[Music]
when you work in the theater you always
begin privately there isn't always an
audience but interestingly there is
always a test of what that relationship
to the audience is going to be so you
begin with your team of colleagues on a
musical you have a big village of people
you have a choreographer a writer a
conductor a musical supervisor and I've
always felt the job of the director is
to get so obsessed with the subject
matter and then your job is to spread
the obsession and you've got to do that
in phases so initially you do it to your
inner team and then there's a moment
where you bring actors into that process
and you have to transmit it to your
actors and then ultimately as a
collective we transmit it to the
audience so my job as the director even
though we don't get in front of the
audience
till the baby is born and it has learned
to walk and has done some tests
you know experiences I almost have to
stand in for the audience at every phase
of the process and I often use this
expression of you know you've got to
wash your eyes clean and you have to
dare to be what Peter Brook called naive
you have to be a naive spectator and you
have to see without desire which is
something I often talk about you know
how can you look at what you've done and
not just get hung up on you know oh gosh
this actor didn't do the line the way I
wanted them know you know you can look
with a lot of desire but you can also
look without desire so you are trying to
stand in for that audience at every
phase and by doing that I think you cast
that audience in your head and you can
make a choice about how you're gonna
cast that audience and I'm a great
believer in
the audience being a great partner in
the audience wanting to stretch you and
the audience wanting to to to learn I
just think their human needs and we want
to learn we want to be moved we want
ritual we want to go through an
experience together in life we want
spectacle there's a human need for the
for spectacle and by spectacle I mean to
be in the presence of something larger
than yourself it's why we stand it on a
beach and look at horizon line and get
lost in it or stand on a mountaintop and
look at a Vista that that's what we
recreate in the theater is an idea of
all in spectacle so you can feel
yourself in the presence of something
greater than yourself so you can make a
choice about how you're thinking about
the audience and wanting to aim high
with your audience on the as I say that
I also believe an audience needs to be
diverted you know this this this French
word divert too small you know we with
entertainment gets a bad word it's like
oh you know it's just fluff it's just
entertainment like no we also have a
human need to be entertained to laugh to
leave our current situation and divert
from that so I guess I try to make a
show the ultimate dream of show is
something that touches on all of those
that you can be challenged in your mind
you can be challenged in your heart I
actually also believe in the body you
know I'm so fascinated with all these
studies of I have a young daughter and I
remember being told when she was in
kindergarten that she might need to see
a specialist because she can't sit still
and then all these studies that have
come out that you know now actually you
know moving helps you learn and now we
know we stand at desks and so this idea
that the theater is a form that actually
also engages you know your body and and
and vibration the other thing about
audience is
I always like to think about the
audience as a creative partner and what
I mean by that is that the audience can
meet you more than halfway and they can
help fulfill the moment so you actually
don't have to micromanage and deliver
everything actually the space that you
leave for the audience to tap their
imagination to complete something to
bring themselves is as important as what
you provide for an audience and I think
that's also really important
in my work with actors when I direct a
show not only am I trying to with the
actor and the playwright or the composer
make all the decisions about how we're
gonna tell the story but I'm also trying
to engage the actor to be creative
because if they are just following
directions it won't be fulfilling and I
think this is something you know that
can be applied to anything you do in
life any kind of business any kind of
group endeavor you know in our business
sometimes actors feel they're a good
actor if they say to the director just
tell me what you want want me to do and
I'll do it you know what what do you
want me to do and to me that is like the
death of a process it's like it's so not
about what I want
actually I start every process with this
statement I say I'm gonna come with an
idea and I'm going to expect you to come
with an idea and I know that together we
will make a third idea that is better
than both of our ideas and that's a
really important thing to say upfront
because we live in hierarchy and people
tend to feel that they're they don't
have space to have an idea that they
need to execute or they need to just
deliver what is expected and I think in
the arts we all know the arts going to
be great when you get to the
expected so we actually are in a
profession that values that but I think
that that idea of giving agency and
empowering anyone you know whether you
are an actor in a show or whether you
sit in the box office or whether you're
a section estat the desk to a company
like at my theater I know everyone I
want everybody the whole endeavor is
going to be better if everyone is as
invested and as engaged in the big
picture so you have to do a lot of
talking about the big picture you know
it can't just be an execution because
people don't understand people get
resentful when they don't understand why
they're being asked to do what they're
doing especially if it's hard work so I
always feel my job as a director is to
constantly point to the top of the
mountain and remind people like we're
going there and guess what and this is
also an important lesson that I've
learned and I always tell this to young
directors you don't have to have the
answers you know a lot of young people
feel like I can't be a director I don't
have a vision I don't have the answers
it is so not about the answer in fact
the whole process is finding the answer
together if you have the answer you have
the wrong answer or you definitely have
not asked a big enough question you know
the idea is together we're gonna find
out how we get to the top of the
mountain I don't know how we're gonna
get there but I know that's what we're
going and then definitely the job of the
director is when everybody's tired and
people are cranky and they're mutinies
because that happens and people just
want to give up and go down the mountain
you have to find a way to engage people
to say come on we're gonna keep going
we're gonna keep going and that's I
would say 75% of what I do as a director
it's keeping people motivated keeping
people engaged and and inspiring people
to have some kind of faith and you can
only do that if you believe in what
you're going so you know that's that
that's so important and and and for me
it has defined my investment in what I
do emotionally spiritually is I will not
take on a project that I don't believe
in because it's too hard
and you know it won't be authentic that
investment of my personal energy and my
personal blood sweat and tears if I
don't believe in where we're going in
the arts in particularly not-for-profit
arts movement there can be a lot of
blaming the audience for the lack of
engagement the audience has left the
building
nobody wants culture anymore in America
we're depraved we have no more attention
span right the Internet has has
corrupted our minds no one wants to sit
in a theater anymore
and I remember hearing all this and
thinking very strongly well we're just
blame in the audience and I'm a producer
and an artist I actually have a chance
to take a little responsibility for
maybe why the audience's left the
building so I want to do everything I
can to ahead of time before the audience
has ever invited into the process to
make something that I think an audience
is going to want to be in the presence
of and by one I mean they want it they
need it and they need it now so I think
in a process with my team and a creative
process we're constantly asking big
questions why are we doing this what
story are we telling why do we care what
are we identifying with should an
audience even bother to stay interested
in this point and and those can be very
scary questions because you don't
because they're big questions and you
don't want them to dismantle your
process to the point where you're
debilitated but if you can find a way to
ask tough questions again to get
everyone around the table thinking and
feeling as hard as they can the work
will get better and that is a process in
the theatre that continues on
gently and the real horror of the
theater is you don't know what you have
until you put in front of an audience so
even though you've tried very hard to
stand in for the audience to make all
your best decisions based on what you're
trusting yourself and your team and the
actors and the small invited guests that
are brought into the room you really
don't know what you have until you have
an audience and then if you're lucky you
have a chance to change it in front of
an audience and then if you're really
lucky you get to continue to work on it
I just did a national tour of Finding
Neverland which is a musical I did on
Broadway and I did it at the AR T at
Harvard I did it on Broadway and ran
over a year on Broadway now it's on tour
we just changed it again and it's a
staggering process to to know that
sometimes you can just get so far with
something and you need to step back look
at it again live your life a little
everybody has to go off and put it in a
drawer and then come back and then you
can see fresh because sometimes this
idea of seeing without desire is not
always possible so that's why we talk
about process we talk about process that
that that there is a process of the work
never being done and how you can
continue to improve something and and in
many cases you improve because you get
feedback and you get feedback from a
very very honest audience and there were
people who said things to me at a RT
when we first did Finding Neverland
that's stuck with me and for many
reasons the actual change we made years
later couldn't happen but now they've
happened and there's nothing more
fulfilling than having a chance to
continue to to to work on something and
make it better
you
[Music]